[Music]
it's Amazon Elastic Compute cloud ec2 is
the backbone of AWS and it truly
redefines how IT departments operate
Amazon ec2 provides a web service that
allows you to create resizable compute
capacity in the cloud so you can
instantly launch instances of any size
operating system and configuration to
meet practically every demand this
lesson identifies the features that make
Amazon ec2 a truly life-changing service
for IT departments we'll take a glimpse
into the future to see how products such
as elastic Beanstalk and lambda are
looking to push the boundaries of IT
architecture even further so what is ec2
what we briefly covered ec2 in Lesson
number one and I'm sure you're all
familiar with ec2 as it's the backbone
of Amazon Web Services basically Amazon
Elastic Compute cloud or ec2 is a web
service that provides resizable compute
capacity in the cloud it provides a
variety of different options to create
your own cloud instances ec2 instances
use EBS volumes on which to store data
you can launch your own virtual servers
Windows Linux etc anywhere in the world
on AWS infrastructure to run your
applications websites databases and more
so let's take a look at some of the
benefits of using ec2 easy to allows you
to increase or decrease your capacity in
minutes you can launch one hundreds or
even thousands of server instances
simultaneously
ec2 offers flexible cloud hosting
services as numerous operating systems
and instance types and software packages
available for you to launch in just
minutes
AWS is designed to be fully integrated
with other AWS products such as s3
Amazon RDS and SQS to name a few the
integration provides you with a complete
IT architecture solution in the cloud
AWS is unbelievably reliable and secure
AWS operates an SLA a commitment of
99.95% availability and if they do miss
their SLA targets you are compensated
however that rarely happens also the use
of Amazon DPC inter you can easily
create secure and robust networks to run
your Amazon ec2 instances Amazon Web
Services are also good value and low
cost AWS charges by the hour so you only
pay for what you use and the hourly
rates are much lower than your existing
on-premise infrastructure in this
demonstration we're going to create a
Linux instance and we're going to
connect to it
you
so firstly we're going to go to the
compute section and click on ec2 and
we'll get the ec2 dashboard and we're
going to click on launch instance and
representative to choose an ami page
which we talked about in the ami session
so here are the Amazon prefect defined a
mas so there's Amazon Linux red hair up
into Microsoft etc and then here is the
my am is we don't have any of those yet
but we're going to do that in another
demonstration here is the AWS
marketplace where there's software
provided by third-party vendors and you
can search through them to find various
things so here's like the SA P offerings
available and then there's the community
AM is where you could select stuff like
Federer 32-bit instance store and
there's a whole selection of things
there for you to provide but for this
demonstration we're just going to launch
in Amazon Linux ami so I'm just going to
click on select and I'm just going to
select a smallest instance available
which is a t2 Nano now we're not going
to configure it at this stage because
we're going to cover that in later
sections so I'm just going to click on
review and launch and this brings us to
the launch page so we have a t2 Nano is
created a third security group for us
with SSH access to the port 22 so I'm
just going to accept all the defaults
here because we just want to launch it
and I just want to show you how you can
connect to it so we click on launch and
it's going to ask us about our key pair
so we can choose an existing key pair I
already have or we can create a new key
pair specifically for these instances so
I'm going to create a new key pair which
will use going forth and I'm going to
call that as you might have guessed
simply learn key pair
and then I'm going to click on download'
key pair because this is the only time
I'll get the opportunity to do that okay
so that's been downloaded and then I'm
going to click on launch instances so
now our instance is being launched so if
we go back to the ec2 dashboard we will
see that our instance is now being
launched now because I didn't do any
configuration and hasn't got a name
so let's just give it quickly a name
simply learn demo click on the tick box
and there we are so we can just see our
instance now it says it's running so if
you click on it and highlight it we can
click on connect and it gives you some
instructions about connecting now
because I'm on the Windows machine I'm
going to connect using putty so to do
that we need to do a few things first so
let me leave this screen now before we
can connect to our Linux instance using
putty we have to convert our key pair
that we downloaded from AWS and to do
that we use the putty key generator so I
already have my key pair saved down on
my desktop so I need to click on ensure
that SSH - to RSA is selected I need to
load an existing private key so if I go
to my desktop
click on that and it tells me that it's
successfully imported my key and now I
want to save my private key are you sure
you want to save this key by the
password yes that's fine so I'll save it
to my desktop and I'm going to call that
simply learn private key and I'll save
that as a putty private key
and there it is so there's Mikey over
there with a nice nice hat on it so then
we use putty to connect so the first
thing is we need to go to connection ssh
authorization and we need to load in our
key pair so i go to the desktop and edit
simply learn private key PPK so i need
to load that in so now that's going to
be our key and give us our authorization
so I go back to session and I'm going to
give this session a name until it's
simply learned and I'm going to save it
so I can use this going forward so now
to connect I need to need to know the IP
address of my instance so let's go back
to AWS management console okay so in the
management console and here's our simply
learned demo the next instance and down
here we can see our public IP address so
we're going to copy that and we're going
to go back to putty so to connect a
party we need to know the IP address
which we've just cut and pasted and we
need to type in ec2 user at the IP
address an ec2 user is the user that you
use to connect to Linux instances so now
we should be good to go so now I just
click on open and it's saying the
service Ock is not cached in your
registry we have no guarantee that
server as the computer you think it is
which is you'll see this is a standard
message you'll see whenever you connect
to an instance you've never connected
you before so I'm going to click on yes
I trust the connection and there we are
so now we've connected to our instance
so whenever you connect to an instance
the good thing to do with v2 sudo to
admin assuming you have that and run yum
update yes and then this way a lot date
all the packages on the instance to make
sure that you're running with the latest
and greatest versions of everything so
it should take a few minutes to run
okay there we are so now our ec2
instance is up and running and that is
how you launch an ec2 Linux instance
very quickly and connect to it
you
in this demonstration we're going to
quickly launch a Windows ec2 instance
and show you how to connect to it
so I'll start with the Amazon Web
Services console we click on compute ec2
and click on launch instance and this
time we're going to select Microsoft
Windows Server 2012 r2 base I'm going to
select the smallest available and like
the previous demonstration I'm not going
to do any configuration this time so as
you can see it's creating a security
group for us but this time rather than
allowing SSH access by default is
allowing us RDP access on port 3 3 8 9
so that we can connect by Microsoft
Remote Desktop so let's click on launch
we're going to get the key pair window
again now this time we don't need to
create a key pair because we already
have our simply learn key pair so we're
just going to click on choose an
existing key pair and click on simply
then and I tick this box to say I
acknowledge that I have access to this
key pair because without this file I
won't better log on to my instance and
then I click on launch instances it says
ok your instances and now launching now
here it is because I haven't given the
name again so let's just call that
simply learn window demo going to copy
that
I'll paste it up here so now we can just
see our instance you can see it's public
IP address down here is public dns so
now our windows instance has been
launched so we need to get the
connection details so we highlight our
instance and because it can't connect so
what we need to do is get the password
and to do that we click on get password
and it tells us it needs to find this
key pair which is our simply zone key
pair so I click on choose file and on
the desktop I have the simply learn key
pair and I click on open and it cuts and
paste it into here and I can click on
decrypt password
so now it tells me this is the Public
DNS for the instance this is the
username is always administrator and
here's the password let me cut and paste
the password and then a nice feature you
can click on download remote desktop
file so I click on that and there it is
so here's our RDP file so all we have to
do is click on the RDP file ignore this
remote connection warning which you'll
see most times type in the password for
the administrator user
it says you can't identify the remote
computer you lost and see that so I
always don't ask me again for this click
yes and now it will start to connect to
our windows instance
so now we can see it's loading up our
user profile
and there we are so now we have launched
and successfully connected to a Windows
ec2 instance hey once you become an
expert in cloud computing then subscribe
to simpler Channel and click here to
watch more such videos
- nerd up and get certified in cloud
computing click here